look out
a burning hot space rock just fell into
your living room destroying all the
things you care about
goodbye sweet television
how did this meteorite end up here
is it still piping hot and dangerous
and
what are the odds this could happen to
you
this is what if and here's what would
happen if a meteorite crashed into your
home
many rocky objects orbit our sun and
depending on their size they could
either be larger asteroids or smaller
meteoroids
if an asteroid was headed toward earth
it would probably spell big trouble for
you and many others
meteoroids on the other hand enter our
atmosphere often
many burn up upon entry becoming meteors
these just aren't destined to reach the
ground
but
plenty of space rocks do complete the
long hot journey to the surface
these are called meteorites and it's
estimated that 44 000 kilograms of them
fall to earth every day
hopefully it won't keep you up at night
knowing a meteorite could be headed
toward you this very second
you are enjoying a quiet night at home
but things are about to get rocky
far above you a meteoroid has just
entered earth's atmosphere at a speed of
10 to 70 kilometers per second
it would slam into the particles in our
atmosphere rapidly compressing the air
in front of it
this would cause the meteorite to glow
and heat up to temperatures as high as
650 degrees celsius
as the rock fell further and further
through our atmosphere the outer layers
would start to burn off most meteoroids
are so small that this burning known as
ablation
is enough to turn them to dust
only about 500 of these fully intact
objects make it to the ground every year
that's less than five percent of all
incoming meteoroids and most end up in
the ocean or other unreachable terrains
but with a one in 840
million chance
you've won the meteorite jackpot
you'd have a better chance of getting
struck by lightning or bitten by a shark
or
both
the meteorite would come in at a low
angle smashing straight through your
bedroom window
you'd wake up to the sound of breaking
glass
shocked to discover a charcoal gray rock
about the size of your fist snuggled up
next to you you'd recoil and nearly roll
out of the bed in total shock
that's when you'd finally become aware
of the aching pain in your side
lifting your shirt you'd notice a nice
big bruise but you'd be amazed that
that's all the harm that it caused
cautiously you'd go to touch it assuming
the rock is still piping hot from its
atmospheric journey
but you'd be surprised to find that it's
barely warm
well that's because small rocky
meteorites are pretty bad at conducting
heat so as all the outer layers burn
away the core remains cool
now confident that you won't get burned
you pick it up to examine it closer
it has some heft and you'd estimate that
it weighs somewhere around four
kilograms
whoa the damage that could have done to
your face
suddenly you notice a surprising odor
filling up your old house and it's
coming from the meteorite
well depending on the composition the
rock could smell like tar
wet hay or your compost
one scientist described the strange
smell as similar to the butt end of a
cigar or old dirt in a vacuum cleaner
well now what would you do
you'd be one of the very few people
unlucky enough to be hit by a meteorite
a quick internet search would tell you
about the silica meteorite
in 1954 a woman in alabama ann hodges
was struck by a meteorite in her sleep
and just like you she miraculously
walked away with only a bruised hip
but wait a second this rock that has
fallen into your possession
could be valuable
maybe even a beautiful addition to some
jewelry
you'd take it to get official
certification and depending on the
rarity of its composition condition of
preservation and aesthetic appeal
it could be worth between five cents and
one thousand dollars per gram
that would mean your little four
kilogram rock
could be worth a lot more than a tesla
maybe you did hit the jackpot after all
okay well the jackpot kind of hit you
but you can thank your lucky space rock
that it wasn't an asteroid on a
collision course with your house
because
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]